oh hi my name is Fanta let's save them
scrub a lot shall we dead and dance
whoa it's Kelly why what the [ __ ] did I
ever do to you what a dick
it's gonna win well this is a good start
this is the one with it all right this
is where we're lifetime hostages have
been hooked up for two explosives I
could say they're my SuperSpeed I can't
get close enough because he's hot which
Lex replies with kryptonite yay
come on get me super stupid all right we
need to save the hostages all right
there's only one thing you can do for a
situation like this super stealth dicks
this is not what I wanted at all all
right I got myself a duck now what's
your plan
Oh No good throw what the [ __ ] are you
doing good super loose this one so I
wish this guy all right duck and khatola
go in first
all right here we are bring it on [ __ ]
somebody out we need to lure him out you
think I'm an idiot kid I know I know I
know I lied active magnetic yes okay
kaboom you two are safe now thanks to
Maxwell gosh thanks Superman
but I did it Maxwell I still can't go
near Matala you'll need to ask him why
he's here my duck is insane
what happens here I'll use my x-ray
vision to take a closer look okay
uh-oh he's working with Lex Luthor
Herbert am thought wait it's a duck
inside my duck I some kinky [ __ ] I have
an idea of something really cool just
give me one second okay I have my metal
duck army with me bring it
me and my metal duck shall rule the
world
oh damn this is worse than a Michael Bay
movie
oh no he spawned crying red Cthulhu what
but you have a Cthulhu it's not fair
all right unicorn fire-breathing power
no yahoodi card I shed my dark side no
the Ducks money now I'm missing my dice
huh come back here please knocks follow
my follow daddy
yes attack ducks I said I forgot ducks
are useless now okay
we need to think about something giant
Oh doh puss go giant why that's not a
god you're supposed to be a duck's do
something
okay how about what's good against
Cthulhu a twerking giant Cthulhu Oh
what where did he go Cthulhu come back
here what the [ __ ] attack him this is so
stupid and tank
I need a tank keep shouting yes so
disappointed in your giant Cthulhu
stopped working khatola the hell are my
ducks doing seriously my Ducks art
working at ultrasonic speed
come on kill him there we go alright
what else you got why are you doing this
why are you helping this villains oh
[ __ ] don't no no no don't don't kill him
are you [ __ ] stupid are you [ __ ]
stupid
do I have to do everything again alright
you have a purple lion oh [ __ ] a purple
flying lion well I know their biggest
weakness go pink Jack why do you sound
like a cheap is that only you have
whoa one shot damn go giraffe holy [ __ ]
you're badass oh he died okay Plan B
exam B dolphin attack him go Sammy
dolphin yes oh [ __ ] he spawned a sugar
but I have a giant sugar somewhere
what's happening
michael bey what the [ __ ] what's the
plan give some man something made out of
kryptonite to knock out Lex I made to
your there you go oh [ __ ] no no no no no
I'm not doing I'm sorry I'm not doing
that ship again
[ __ ] that huh because you have to do
everything again it's ridiculous okay
I'm gonna spawn my hipster there you go
why are you crying yeah you can have
this hipster what is hipster one hey
what okay what are you doing with my dog
hipster there we go alright let's go
with da car me what are you doing you're
coming with this helpless fine and take
down madman yellow okay
oh I found him alright what is this
crazy [ __ ] one get him ducks my duck
army tells everyone hell yeah hip sarah
and ducks shall rule the world use this
torch to light the ticket torch okay I
can do that steal all my ducks
you tricked me
kill them absurd kill them that's right
I'll bring on his memory da what do you
whine try to dive through the Ring of
Fire
okay how yeah [ __ ]
whoa
[Laughter]
I'm so awful at this game
okay this is [ __ ] awkward as hell but
let's go I don't know what happened to
the game all right we shall jump the
trampoline come on sugar
bring your a-game come on [ __ ] I did it
we did it I think what is going help me
protect myself okay fire breath oh how
about a laser sword you don't really
have arms so I don't see how it okay
whoa damn thank you
what is going on here
get me an escape vehicle how about an
awkward running dolphin there you go gah
that was awkward
what not completed I mailed that [ __ ]
[ __ ] all right what do you want she
doesn't even want anything all right
what do you want I have a flat replace
my bags front tire dolphins are the
solution of everything I swear to God
there you go
why are you taking golf it okay it's
looking at mr. broccoli and that will
work anyway
really there you go have fun have a good
life what is it what is happening here
shoo go away pan what but why so cute
what if I give you some food hey I have
a duck oh that's sad I have nothing left
to live for
really Wow way to be overdramatic she
threw my dead duck oh that [ __ ] is
going down yeah that's right I'm hitting
the table
everyone just died but I lost my dingo
it only comes out under moonlight well
let's make it night there you go ooh
sexy how do you like me now
oh dude what are you doing me cat yard
and make an any Santa mamma
alright well you're welcome all that's
left of my little duckling this game is
racist again that's racist hmm need some
more vegetables well Ducks are the
solutions of everything ducks aren't
vegetable how about a vegetarian Jack
really tastes like chicken
good good genius
bird strikes again ok ok nailed it we
did it we got 1500 which means we
unlocked the Superman symbol so we can
do Superman's origin story why is that
guy bent over that's really awkward all
right I don't know what the hell they
were doing at Metropolitan anyway I've
done the Zoe I hope you bros enjoyed
watching leave a like if you did it
helps out a lot let me know if you want
more I'm scribbling it's a lot of fun to
play so I wouldn't mind it it's a
subscriber come read today I'll see you
tonight
[Music]